hi I've been making uh these films now
for
nearly three years and averaging out
around 100 a year
I
have done those are new to me I've done
technical ones and mainly talking
because
I feel that there's so much out there in
the world that you know on YouTube and
places that you can you can find quality
Aikido techniques weapons or take it to
different styles
and um you know you can follow them for
entertainment reasons or or for learning
purposes
all my films are made for learning
or giving
and um
you know after a journey of nearly 50
years I feel like
because I can't get out so much because
of sadly the restrictions in the world
through Wars or covid
uh I haven't done as many seminars as I
used to
I averaged uh about a dozen a year you
know give or take
two or three but about a dozen a year
I'd be subtracting somewhere in the UK
or the world to teach a seminar
um but when you can't do that I thought
I'll sit here and and give those
who wish to live look and listen and
perhaps my thoughts on
my journey and also
may help you have light bulb moments as
we call it and suddenly go Ah that's
what that's what it means that's what it
means
okay
this particular film I've given it a lot
of thought over the years and I'm not
sure because I haven't asked anybody if
this is me talking to myself in this
case
or whether it's going to be of value to
you
you see we're all individuals
and let me put it in a an analogy that
in the UK
we almost seem to be able to now
changing TV channels
almost constant uh programs on different
chefs showing us how to make wonderful
meals
and um we get like in Aikido we get to
like certain chefs we might like two or
three we might not be completely focused
on just one
and we might like
control three some may be better for
desserts than main meals
some might be better for starters
now to me any martial art
that I've seen
it's like the food is all there for all
the same chefs any of the chefs that are
on TV can choose from the food from the
around the world
but it's how they put the dishes
together that makes them unique
and that's what makes them stand out
now to me oh since he gave us
the techniques
most people follow the technical side
and like the dynamic side of the
training in Aikido
but but I I meet really nobody who's
prepared to
including myself I I don't do the
the constant chanting in the mornings
and I don't pray to the gods the
chemistor
the kamehameh the Gods
I don't see in front of the small wooden
house on the Showman
and think that there's the spirits
inside the house that will come to help
me
in my daily Quest
so there's lots of things I don't
believe in but I try to do what I can to
um it's a bit like I take the
ingredients that I want to make my
particular
menu
and I've always been an oddball you know
well I think I have I've always been an
individual
and I'm talking to you as an individual
aren't I
but you may be like one of the herds you
may be like happy to just be in the
field like all those other cows or sheep
and I'm not trying to be rude to you or
belittle you but you may be just happy
turning up on the mat training
being sociable going home until the next
the next lesson that you wish to go to
and the majority of people I've found
are happy to do that
it's only us die hards Fanatics who who
want to live it 24 7. the problem with
that is work life
family everything else gets in the way
but it doesn't stop this does it it
doesn't stop this
thinking
and trying to analyze
so let's put it another way
you've got all the ingredients that you
wish to choose
and you'll look at foods that
you like you won't pick I can't stand
beetroot
my giant loves beetroot so I'd never
pick beetroot to make a dish
And yet when I've been teaching him
Masha one of the most tastiest dishes
dishes is borsche and Porsches
um
that's a traditional Russian soup
made with beetroot it has that lovely
ready color but it doesn't taste at all
like a a piece of beetroot that I've had
cooked for me
thank you
and the only reason I tried the Bush was
because I was trying to be polite they
put it in front of me or you must try
this since he hits the
the you know the most Russian this year
you'll have this is going back to the
early 90s when
they're all very poor still and
and trying to make their way up into the
life I went to the first ever McDonald's
in Saint Petersburg
and the queue
was massive but the shop was minute at
that time
and um I'm digressing
so you'll only choose what you want
and this is the same perhaps with Aikido
those of us who have done the weapons
must have favored the weapons to want to
do it because I teach people
and any warmer Rio
the school of iroma
We Do 50
weapons and fifty percentage
this is the balance this is what our
sensei's balance was and this is what
our balance is
in the mornings he would do the weapons
in the evening class he would do
taijitsu
you say
a lot of people say
a lot of the top teachers actually they
say oh you don't need weapons
to do Aikido
they could be right
if you want to just do
make a souffle you know make something
nice and tasty
but we're talking about martial art here
and I keep emphasizing martial art
budo budo means Marshall and what Buddha
means Hawaii
a way of doing something so therefore
we use the weapons because it helps us
align our body it helps us to
flow Under Pressure it allows us to
overcome panic
if you become good enough it would take
you to fear and eventually be unfair so
that there is no Panic fear anymore
this film will be strange in many years
to come
well I hope it is still there
um but the moment the Russian and Europe
Ukraine war is going on
and there's going to be a lot of fear on
both sides
some will be not able to settle day or
night
it'll be complete torment
not only for those in the trenches and
fighting
for the people that the people in the
cities have got no experience of fear or
how to handle it
they think that they're perhaps in daily
life
had fear or had to deal with situations
but never anything like this
sound of a bomb going off and the
vibration coming
along the ground to where they stand if
that may not be close to them
fear
it can be overcome in Aikido
so of course I'm not on the battlefield
so how can I talk about it well I
believe I can because I've reached the
point where Beyond fear
you realize that death is the next step
because you you have to decide
whether you're going to put
death as a fear or death as something
that may happen there's nothing you can
do about it
but using your skills
you can do your best to avoid it
so even while not wishing to die
um
you're past the point of trying too hard
not to die
because you may be
not open to seeing all the advantages
that you could have
um while not panicking
not having fear in your life
and accepting what will be will be but
with eyes wide open not sort of cowing
in a in a situation where oh please God
help me
laughs God is not here anymore
and
to me he has no body
he has no voice box he doesn't eat he
doesn't need to sleep if it is a he
whatever this
being is
then
they can transmit through vibrations
and through vibrations we can hear but
not with our ears but telepathically
our brains are so intelligent that we
convert vibrations into words that we
understand
so God or aloe or anyone that you may
believe in
or not believing
you can have voices in your head
and perhaps the voices will guide you to
keep safe
so to me this is the menu of life
this is the food of life
preserve yourself and to be an
individual
so this talk that I'm giving may be an
absolute waste of your time listing
but we do the weapons in Aikido to make
us efficient in body movement alignment
awareness
flexibility speed stamina
all the things one needs to keep fit and
healthy
if you only do the taijitsu
you may be happy with that
but you're only getting a part of the
ingredients
but if that part of ingredients you're
happy with
then
keep with it because
in the end of the life we must look back
and be happy with what we've done and
what we've given back to life
and if we've been adventurous and
perhaps tried the gauch
and said hmm I didn't think I'd like it
but you know that was very tasty but I
still won't eat
um raw or cooked beetroot in its slices
so we make it we have a choice don't we
so this has really been a talk about
be an individual
try to realize that the ingredients that
I've sent it gave us
are like the foods from the world
but it's up to us
what we take from that food and what we
will how we will use it within our body
within our thinking
I'll make another film now
going into my own personal thoughts on
what I've gained from this type of
thinking
and not just said I don't like that I
don't want it
at any cost
reminds me of my
my grandchildren
no no I don't want it down like well try
it we're all guilty of that I think if
we're grandparents or parents we'll just
try it no I don't want to try I don't
want to try it and then as we grow up
we start smoking or drinking beer or
alcohol
it's horrible at first well from what I
remember the smoking or the drinking it
tasted horrible
and yet
all the adult type people even as a
teenager you know you think that you
want to be an adult faster than you
should be
so you keep drinking it and before you
know where you are y'all
you're drinking it it tastes fine
so
there'll be techniques in Aikido that
you like
targets and weapons
and as I said I teach people around the
world and I can look at them and I just
know that they don't not enjoying the
weapons
or I'll watch them do certain techniques
and they really don't like them
and it's a little bit like I'm watching
and watching and that's all I can do I
can only just watch and wait
and then
some people I've watched people now for
over 40 years
helping my students and they still today
don't like the weapons or they do like
weapons
than the first time I ever taught them
And yet when I say to them you don't
like the weapons do you they will insist
oh yes and say oh yes I do I do but the
body language is telling me that they
don't
that's perhaps another story okay I hope
you've enjoyed listening and um
there's more thought-provoking I'm
trying to do here
the world has many things to offer not
just in food but in experiences
we must not take the food
That Others May like
and leave it in the cupboard looking at
it thinking I'll try it and in the end
it goes in the bin because you never
really had any
firm intentions
you had an intention when you bought it
but you didn't really want it in the
first place but you thought you'd ought
to try it
it's been a total waste to do that where
somewhere else in the world could have
gained from that
food
Aikido to me
has all the ingredients I've done on
other Arts but to me Aikido has all the
ingredients but you may need other Arts
to unlock the ingredients that Scentsy
gave us
because Aikido is a very complex start
very deep very difficult to understand
someone said to me once oh yes it's an
old man's Judo
they were saying that once the bodies
had enough of sports
and a competition
you can sort of settle down to the
Aikido
talking to my master type about Tai Chi
and its slow beautiful movements
and him pointing out oh no no it's it's
Kung Fu it's the same movements as a
young person does in kung fu it's just
slowed down because we're older but it
has the same powerful effects
killing abilities breaking abilities
but we can't do it anymore like we did
when we were young
okay so I hope this has been a benefit
and worth listening to
and I hope it provokes some thoughts
about how you wish to reconsider your
journey or improve your own menu thank
you for your time